all right i have hit start recording i
have hit start recording
and i punched it good i hit it right in
the face yeah
let's see it how about everyone else
everyone else hit it
i am recording uh our man on the street
mike bithell either that or he's he's
the maybe you're the door guy
i don't see on the list yeah you guys
did look particularly handsome today
mike i feel like he looks like he's a
bartender at a really bougie like
cocktail place
he's like i mean that is i was once a
bartender at a particularly bougie
cocktail place so
nailed it can i make you an
old-fashioned exactly
i'm gonna i wasn't a good bartender but
i was a bartender
yeah i can't tell if it's a bartender an
excellent game designer
well there you go no not frozen just
focused
you okay austin have you seen a ghost
what's happened to you
i was starting to admire him as a statue
i was like look at the lines
i think he's maybe being respectful by
not saying anything until he's recording
which is actually very nice
wow that's great okay let's do it thumbs
thumbs up from austin there we go
i was i was changing my settings
and i realized it was slightly
excused poorly yes exactly it was a skew
and um so better to remain silent and
thought a fool
is that right a skew and a cute askew is
you should come in and haul with lots of
questions today cute hey
three weeks to make up for y'all you've
had your reprieve
you've had your respite from me yeah
what would you like to talk about
yeah troy why don't we just be quiet and
you just tell us what do you want to
talk about troy yeah what's up oh my god
i missed you guys that's what i want to
talk about i don't want to talk about
him
i love that subject tell us about how
great we are troy
you are you're welcome in fairness we
did talk a lot about how great you are
in your
absence
you did this one thing where you're like
oh by the way it's not here
yeah that was pretty bad i definitely
should have addressed i didn't care
i didn't cry
um i no first of all let's go around the
room
um austin already knows what i think
about him i got to watch austin work
like in his element and one of my
favorite ways to watch austin work
can i can i say where we were is that
okay yeah okay
so i've i've been to most of the stages
i think on um in in
hollywood uh i've been to
the i've got like the places you're
supposed to record i've been there like
i've been to frank sinatra's old place
which was cello studios and now it's um
east west
i've been to capitol records uh i went
to todd ayo before it was gone
like i got to go to these i didn't get
to go at a m but these
beautiful stages beautiful studios um
but i'd never been to fox
and that's like legendary and
uh austin was was doing a demo there his
audition cost hims a lot of dollars
i gotta g i did an audition like 10
minutes ago it took me like three
minutes
and i drink a couple coffees nothing he
like spent two weeks
and hired a bunch of people had to do
covid tests all this stuff was like
i can never complain about an audition
again yeah so i he let traveler and i
come there and
and and the monk and i got to watch him
work and it was like this brilliant
thing
so i got to watch austin uh and then
mike
i i talked about you uh nick dixon and i
did a
a cool little fireside chat and he just
sang your praises
and i readily convinced him how full
hearty he was in believing those they're
all rumors
no we had a great talk and then alana i
have been just
i found out that i have cockles okay
because they've been warmed
by seeing you with your family and your
do you call it motherland is probably
better we just call it homeland
yeah okay home it's just probably better
because there's no like weird flags or
anyway um this was great seeing you like
there with your dad i get that a lot
it's always very nice whenever i go home
the amount of people who are like
wow you're really happy and it's very
obvious and i'm like i should continue
posting this content
because i am really happy whenever i'm
home even though it's freezing cold
right now
watching italy humanizes somebody right
it's not not like you're not humanized
it's just that we've established that
she doesn't
have you seen like a a dip in people
because you people come at you hard
you know you and you because you're
stepping out you're saying something
and and you you put yourself in the
spotlight but do you think that people
have been like
pretty naturally remarkably kinder or
less
i don't read enough to say so i don't i
can't i couldn't tell you
like didn't you get your first like
gamer angry
game dev related delay yeah
congratulations
so yeah somebody way to ruin a franchise
i got one of those this week that's
great
um yeah somebody sent me an angry uh dm
uh because the next god of war game got
delayed
nationally you shouldn't have done it
you shouldn't have done that and i would
like to apologize for that let a girl be
in charge
on ps4 which i thought was very funny
but it was a very weird experience for
me because i shared this thing being
like
oh it happened cool um
but then so many people at the studio
reached out to me and was so
nice and so concerned in a way that i
was like
you're all being absolutely wonderful
but none of this is necessary
it was like something i couldn't find a
[ __ ] to give about this having to be
like it looks completely fine um i i
keep having to be like
you guys are being absolutely lovely but
this doesn't matter to me
whatsoever and the upside is this is
no what's the upside is that somebody
tried to do something
very negative it had absolutely zero
negative impact and instead created
something really positive where like
you know i met so we should do more of
that it was like you didn't even realize
what positivity
well done to austin for sending it well
well that's what it's worth
about the account for right yeah that's
what i was going to say is is
the subtext is the subtext that i should
not send you dm's like that when i'm
frustrated about
pushing release dates because it's
delayed it's a it's a way i
vent look i feel like everyone has their
own sort of self-care
uh strategies mine is sending you really
really vile angry things under anonymous
accounts that maybe applies to a number
of men i don't think you're alone there
have you considered therapy this is my
therapy
and this is for women
but how cool is that though to know that
you've got that support network so many
games don't do that good a job of kind
of looking after people when they come
under fire so no they were absolutely
yeah when i communicated with them i was
like i knew when i took the job
this would happen and i know going
forward that it's gonna happen anytime
anyone's upset about anything
um like i was fully aware of that and
they were like okay we'll make sure we
loop you in on future announcements so
you know if you want to take time off
social media that you could do that like
it was so
nice in a way that i was like wow you
really care about people like you are
sony and naughty dog uh especially
really
like they they rallied around us and and
formed a human shield and i was like
dude i'm good i've i've
i've spent enough time and like people
coming after laura that's a different
thing and i even
like laura is stronger than all of us
but uh i still
i saw those arms yeah dude it's tough uh
she gave birth what have i ever done
yeah that's true um i
you know i didn't um i didn't
particularly you know like stuff
that they people were saying about her
and stuff and i definitely came to her
age she's like i got this i'm good
um but it was it was very um comforting
i've never been in a situation like that
before where
the studio and the publisher really were
like
hey we got you um because i've been on
both sides of that with and honestly in
i've been on both sides so like i've
said stuff that i shouldn't say
and sony came to me they're like hey we
don't talk [ __ ] about our own
and i was like i actually like that i'm
on the receiving end of this because
that means that if someone ever talks
[ __ ] about me
you guys are going to be there so it's
it's not this
it was very um there's no double
standard there
so brought to you in part by sony
it is interesting how i i've actually
i've actually gotten
it's funny because i've never
i've never even felt the instinct
i've worked on projects obviously that
you know didn't turn out
as as as the aspirations as on day one
you know
things sometimes drift off the course
and it happens in a way that you don't
really
realize it till it's time to ship
especially seeing this with movies you
know where
the script is is great and then by the
time you come back from the set
you know circumstances change that actor
wasn't on their game and that threw off
this shoot and then that delayed that
day and you had to drop that scene it's
like
this domino effect of things happen that
make things you know it's really every
time you see an amazing film you
play an amazing game it's more like a
miracle that it got there
than it is an aberration because it's so
hard to make things that are great and
so but nonetheless having been on things
before where
everyone's you know okay let's do this
thing and having their big
pow wow at the beginning and by the time
it ships it's a little bit like
it's never been my instinct to do
anything other than to try to represent
like the best version of it out there
like the idea of
sort of trying to you know distance
myself maybe or i don't know why people
would do that i've always maybe it's
just because of
being on the inside you're very aware of
how hard people worked and that it's not
usually occasionally but not usually one
person or even a couple people's
failings it's just that gradual kind of
attrition that happens but interestingly
over the last few years i've actually
seen it show up in my contracts that i'm
explicitly forbidden
from saying bad things about the project
uh or anyone involved
uh i i see i see like it's kind of a
cousin of a non-compete clause in a way
that it basically says you know you
agree to uh
no negative uh sort of public messaging
about it um and it's it's
it's uh how do you feel about that i've
never seen that before
well it's one of those where i always
say you know
like what's the what's the how do you
define that
and also what's the kind of like what
would they do i guess sue me like what
would be the what would be the mechanism
of enforcing that contract
is always the question but well it's not
that's like a lot of contract stuff it's
there to kind of prevent you it's not
necessarily thought out what they would
do in that situation it is becoming a
deterrent
we've we yeah we're just meant to scare
you basically into just shutting up it's
i've definitely seen it in contracts
like you say kind of it's also come up
as something like that
i've been asked if we want to do or the
or when we're working with
with people if and for me it's like
that's that's a very slippery slope the
kind of the nda on whether we're good
people
is a very very slippery slope towards
actual
like tyranny and growth [ __ ] i mean
that's true like if ubisoft had that
right now
and and the clause where nobody can talk
about any of the
kind of harassment stuff that's been
going on there then you could
potentially just hurt a lot of people
but wouldn't it be like if it was a
legality issue
like if they were hey these people are
then then that would
obviously supersede any kind of you
can't have a a a
a contractual obligation that's super
super goes against the law yeah i think
you're probably
right no but you can convince the layman
that it does
and oh yeah you're right as well in a
lot of cases especially with
um well for example harvey weinstein was
well known for
for constantly throwing nda's everyone
like
you know and i'm definitely not going to
say anything that would get me in
trouble legally
um but he was known to do that uh and he
was known to do other things why do you
have things you know about what harvey
weinstein
no i have no idea
my point is like it definitely it's not
so much like
yes of course like you know you the the
legal system would override that
but at the same time like if you're
scared if you're someone who's
intimidated by that you don't know
what's going on
and also in a lot of cases with these uh
sexual discrimination or harassment
or or worse situations there you don't
necessarily know if you have a full
legal
case at the point where you would want
reasonably to make an accusation or to
protect people from that person right
you don't know you have a
iron-clad case so it kind of it does
stifle in that way
or even still i know people that
did and they don't want to be
the they don't want to be remembered for
that
like even if you did you're like i do
have a legal case but this is what i'll
be known for
and also people like that's that's the
problem with coming forward is that no
matter what you do people will be like
i disagree i don't think that happened
i'm like i don't need to hear
what a thousand strangers think of what
happened to a woman who got assaulted
or yeah or anything that happened to and
there's it's not just women right
there's there's yeah look at the the
stories of um
uh oh my god i want to draw a blank on
his name um
brendan fraser right who was like all of
a sudden became a pariah because
he's you know stepped out was like yo
this shit's going on right now and and i
was
there's there's the prevalence
of predatory behavior on varying levels
and i'm not talking about just sexual
i'm talking about it even comes to
hey we're going to make you do this and
we're going to in some way
intimidate you to believe that this is
just our culture and this is what is
acceptable
um in this dude even i'm going to go
back to west wing
watching west wing there was a comment
that didn't necessarily age very well
even though it's a wonderfully
i understand the purpose of the scene
but people would rip it apart
where uh martin sheen's character goes
is just after he's been
you know re-elected and he was like
she goes yeah uh cj played by um
alison gianni says yes mr president he
goes i am mr president
that they just made mr president again
that means i can slap you on the ass if
i want to
and the purpose behind that comment was
him showing confidence and he was like
i'm bulletproof they tried to stop us
and they couldn't
but someone could take that out as an
abstraction and be like this show is
sexist or
it was like ah well you have to watch
three scenes of this to contextualize
that comment
i don't know what i'm talking about
anymore it's funny because i look at
that i think you're defending an old
show for having some slightly dated
stuff with it
yeah it's going to inevitably well it's
funny how i look at that through the
angle hold up troy pull up
[Laughter]
it's funny because i see that as a show
that is probably
accurately representing the inherent
personality type that is drawn to the
presidency
and like their belief that now that i'm
here it's the nixonian
you know if the president does it it's
no longer illegal
kind of belief like i look at that and i
go oh well i'm sorry
sorry austin you can't be moving into
impressions
nailed it no we have we have lines in
the sand here otherwise troy's gonna
start playing
yeah my favorite was you did that once
when we were tracking one of these and
none of us could hear anything
like just you
i do have a question that came that came
up
um but if you have a if you have a topic
or whatever you want to get to then i'm
down to get into it
go ahead mine's way off topic
great how can it be off of a topic i
mean we've not said topics so yeah
exactly
austin's yeah is there a game
yes that the remaining four
um is there a game that you are like
what do you mean you've never played
that and you're uh
ashamed or afraid to admit that you
haven't like if you were to say i've
never played that game people you would
get publicly ridiculed speaking of
mine's chrono trigger i've never played
chrono trigger and i feel like i should
have
you weren't alive that's true
there's a lot of games that weren't look
at my pinky um
there's a lot of games that were you you
retroactively played games that were
a thing before you were a thing yeah
that's why that one stands out as a game
that i should have played
and i think you could get it on ds
couldn't you didn't they release it or
am i
am i just thinking yeah it'll be on
but i just i just know that that's a
game that i should play that i have not
played and that i think about often
like i really should play this game i'm
aware of it i was alive i was two when
it came out
well you have no excuses
i rescind my defense it is on yes
oh my god it's even on ios now i'm not
gonna do it 1995 role playing game
developed and published by square enix
[Music]
originally released for the snes yep
and then it's not cool i don't know how
i'd play it now though
it does say ios but i'm like dude
maybe it's on pc dude there's a new game
called stick game what is it stick or
stick fighter
have you heard about this no it is
a little stick man a name stick fight
great physics
isn't that like a really old game is it
like something that was like an old
flash
is it like i don't know it's
it's made by landfall what is it what
the people oh my god
does anyone else have an answer to the
question yeah i'm i'm sitting here kind
of ignoring your
rabble right now while i try to think of
my answer
um i don't know you know the first one
that came to mind
journey i've never played it
yep thomas yeah wouldn't that be the
funniest revelation in this moment
by the way i love talking about how much
i love that game but i just really want
to look cool
um i the the first one that came to mind
but i feel like there's a lot of people
that would say the same and so it's
not it wouldn't be as sort of uh pariah
inducing is i've never played any elder
scrolls game
um i've always i've always had an
aversion to games of that
that scope where i just think i'm never
going to escape like i remember
jack atridge saying that he finished uh
red dead 2 at like 180 hours of gameplay
and he goes i feel like i have stockholm
syndrome i love this thing that has
held me captive and um
sidebar did you know that stockholm
syndrome has been completely
discounted by the psychology community
somebody else hmm it was an excuse
it was an ex i mean there's a lot of
history there but it essentially boils
down to
um a really mismanaged hostage situation
like the devil maybe do it it's just
kind of like one of those convenient
excuses
well it's specifically it's kind of an
excuse for bad policing because
essentially a hostage situation was
mismanaged and
act to the extent that the hostage
takers were kind of
respected and helped out by the people
they'd taken hostage
or at least kind of that the hostages
kind of
sided with them on some arguments i
don't think it was a friendship or
anything but like it was
it was you know a more kind of
collaboration to the problem free
healthcare is good
like dog days at noon they kind of start
going for the bank robbers
it's basically a justification for why
that situation
would turned out the way it did which
you know yeah it's really it's really
interesting but
but isn't it but how but how do we i i
i've never researched this but just
intuitively doesn't it
seem um
plausible there are so many instances of
people
sort of tormenting their captors in sort
of warping them to such a degree of
dependency and sort of a veneer of
loyalty
out of total fear isn't that essentially
what that just that's
described well know specifically
stockholm syndrome was the concept that
you actually fall in love with that
which damages you
which which there is isn't there much
evidence or
is it any kind of love like an actual
kind of like a like
some some kind of empathy for is
essentially a movie about stockholm
syndrome
right what i'm making is that that's not
really something that happens in the
real world it's just natalie portman
shaved her head
she shaved her head how do we get to
stockholm syndrome
yeah you're basically mike is
undermining my ability to defend why i
haven't uh
played uh elder scrolls games no i get
that i think when it's a really long rpg
that's not even like a
oh i don't want to play this game it's
like i don't want to spend 200 hours on
one thing which else
and i know why is that big and i know i
will just that's the thing
i know i will i have like this i'm like
the character building screen you can
spend that much time on that that's the
thing that i don't like about it
tripod and i did an entire like six
minute epic song
entirely about the character creation
screen uh in skyrim that
it's never about the gameplay it's
entirely about a lot of times the lore
of the characters yeah and i yeah that's
that to me i i
i don't mean to make light of a thing
that's not that's that is actually
serious but i feel like a recovering
addict with games like that where i have
i genuinely have a hard time breaking
free of them
uh to the point that i've sometimes just
one day had this moment where i go you
know what
i'm just going to uninstall it because
because every time i play
i'll go i'm going to play for an hour
like finishing the main quest is not
enough for you
no no that was the thing that's why i
always resented uh ac games because like
i remember on the third one when they
had the side quest of um
the um the feathers in the dust in here
is disparaging
he's breaking his contract
i resented them because i love them but
i i had to do
i had to do the side quests and some of
them were not as interesting as others
and finding feathers and trees and ac3
do not represent austin austin yes
i know that i can't wait for the same
i'm similar if i play an mmo though i
have played a lot of them i get really
sucked into them for like
six months and then i don't play
anything else but i'm okay with it or
like do anything else don't like work or
eat no
especially when i was in university i
was playing uh a lot of
uh neverwinter and guild wars 2 at the
same time which is
two mmos and uh just swapping between
the two and occasionally playing them
even in
lecture halls on a laptop while i'm
supposed to be watching a lecture
because i just couldn't start playing
mmos i don't know that it was that cool
i don't i don't know anarchy
that was me that was me with everquest
like i was playing that game
and i would arrange my schedule to
maximize the amount of hours that i'd be
able to
to play and when that when i realized
the extent to which it was sort of
holding its sway over me i thought
this is at some point it's not even fun
i don't even know that i have fun while
playing the game i just have this need
to to kind of level up or
you know find random rare loot and blah
blah so i i just
canceled it and i remember wow came out
you know initially because it's obvious
like 20 years ago wow
dropped shortly thereafter to this day
i've never played
never played even five minutes of it and
uh the one
the one that every now and again risks
pulling me in is eve online i look at
that
and i'm like so yeah and the things the
bold things that they do
in that that their community just
embraces is so awesome to me that i was
like man if i didn't have a career and
think things that like would operations
yeah
looking for the book that you've got to
get because i love the eve books
so didn't they just release a new one
recently mike do you see that because of
you by the way do you see the book on my
chair
there god yeah can you tell what that is
for audio listens it's emphasizing that
font is
precariously close to uh copyright
infringement
it's lovely it's a history book it's
gorgeous
who is he's a history yeah so cool but i
will never touch it
what book are you talking about austin
winter yeah awesome yeah i was saying
mike do you see what can you can you
quite
make out is that it's the animator's
survival okay it is yep
because of you i bought that book what
yeah i'm impressed by quite proud that i
guessed from that view
it was i was like i was on par with troy
dave in about four notes
he'll be there somewhere do you have an
answer to the question mike
i have too many answers to the question
there it is the last of us part two
yeah exactly i've played last must part
two i haven't simply not played finished
all of last of us so we will continue to
shame you for this
you said you hadn't played it at all i
thought no he stopped around oh
nice stop all gone no i was worried i'd
spoil it because i think i know where
you stopped but then i was worried if i
said something
too far ahead then i stopped asking i
think mike let's say
just after a very natural changing of
the guard i'll put it that way
yeah thank you you know we've all played
it you don't actually really need to
worry about us
well we have people who listen to this
podcast i know they're only like you buy
the house
did you get to the house afterwards did
you meet did you meet ellie
i i got i mean i got past the house
with an excellent scene with you troy
you mean you mean a different
house or a different one that styles he
means there's an excellent scene huh
yeah
i felt i felt i saw most of your
performance i'll put it that way oh no
that's
not the house he's referring to then no
you have not
yeah oh okay that might be what gets me
back to it is just to continue my
experience it's a very
no i've not played anything like that's
the thing as a game designer as well
people expect you to have played
absolutely everything and i've not
played there are massive gaps i've never
played dark souls
that's the one that like as a game
designer i really should like i've had
i've had i had a boss buy me dark souls
i've got dark souls on my shelf i've
just never got out the cellophane like i
need to play that
i think i only played dark souls 2 i
never played dark souls
well i might get the um i might get it
on the the ps5
i mean you should yeah play damon souls
it's fantastic
apologies yeah yeah i've not yeah for me
it was i came in like i played sakiro
or sakura i also loved sakura it was
pronounced i talked to segrow because
uh lana pierce do you know her that's me
i've seen her work
that was the one response that's me i
did delay that game and also
put it on uh playstation 4. responsible
for all of that personally
yeah i don't know why they might be the
meetings but i make all the decisions
you know
i have to say in fairness in fairness
okay
oh no because maybe i don't understand
the tech
but and i think it it comes from not
understanding the tech but i
i i do i do well i think it's ridiculous
to
get upset and throw kick and scream
about any game industry related news
short of like criminal activity i do
understand the
eyebrow rays at the ps4
uh launch ass aspect to that of of
when it when something is sold as you
know next gen to the point of
you know like the ps5 hardware it
capabilities being so beyond that which
came before
making something that has to uh sort of
bow to the limitations of the
predecessor i can see
and as someone who doesn't fully know
the ins and outs of the tech going
well but wait a minute you know you just
sold me this thing
what's what am i missing i see i don't
think that that is an outrageous thing
for people to have
is that what people are annoyed about
it's cross-platform well the idea is
that everybody's fighting like crazy to
get a ps5 and then it becomes less
crucial when a game
that you know is theoretically why
you're trying to get one does
i get the argument now again i'm not
defending the outrage i know it's
interesting i didn't know that was what
the outrage was because like that was
how it was with mars morales
well but but that came out like right on
the the line of
it's always an expectation that you
think there's like a natural cutting off
or sorry they they are saying there
should be a natural cutting off point
where everything is ps5
what's your view i'm joking this is well
this is where i
this is where i just i'm i'm trying to
essentially steel man that position and
say what is
what is the charitable read on that
again not excusing
stupid outrage but just the idea that
well you know at what point is it
better to or not better but what point
is it safe to just say
it's ps5 from here forward where does
that line
fall dude they just stopped you doing
stuff for ps3
i don't mean like i think i think the
issue is platform aspect
so you're saying third parties were
doing support but
it's it is i don't think there's a
problem with it like why i'm sorry
i'm interested what question go ahead
mike i don't think anyone was asking was
it oh oh well
i think i'm gonna i don't i don't see
the problem personally i think it's i
think especially i think arguably this
generation shift more than any previous
is
yes one had a ps4 written on it one has
ps5 written on it but they are upgrades
of a very similar hardware
underlying it so it does make sense to
me that like
i've loved going back i've gone back on
my ps5 and played a bunch of ps4 games
with the great frame rate with the with
the speedy loads i'm i'm
i'm seeing it as an upgrade rather than
necessarily a new generation
so far but then you see something like
ratchet and clank you're like oh no
that's the new generation that's the
well
and that's that's kind of where yeah i
think that's where it's coming from is
people saying
given what's possible does that mean
that this game
is you know not achieving all that's
possible does that mean that the game is
i mean
not to get too boring about it but like
i'm just
fascinated so this is the god of war
thing right so this is
uh is it ragnarok is it god of war
ragnarok is this killing you alana that
you're giving me the death stare here
she's she's she's she's just she's
looking you know who she's looking at
she's looking at the sony lawyers saying
i'm not saying anything is there a red
dot that's moving on her forehead
but this is so so real talk like and
this is something i think players maybe
don't get and to be
fair they don't get it to an extent
because it's not in developers or
publishers interest for them to get it
if you're playing a god of war game
that's coming out like
two years after the last god of war game
you're playing an expansion you're
playing something built on the shoulders
of the game that came before it
so therefore you know you are playing
essentially like an
add-on pack of very great and to be
clear sony's part these are super
polished the most morales one is
excellent but these are
extensions of the previous game rather
than like completely new
from scratch iterations certainly yeah
so i think it probably falls in
i i think i where where i'm really
fascinated to see it is
the horizon zero dawn is also ps4 right
i think
yeah there's rumors of that being the
case if that if that turns out to be the
case that's the one that i think the
technically nerdy
game devs are really interested to see
because that's a game that theoretically
has been built
specifically for ps5 being downgraded
back to ps4
yeah and you know and seeing how that
goes will be really interesting like
that's the one i'm kind of more
intrigued by
it does occur to me that in that same
vein it could be that possible
possibly some of the fire that that
inspired
is sort of an aftertaste of the
disparity between ps4 and ps5
performance on cyberpunk
which was pretty pretty massive actually
like i tried playing cyberpunk on my ps4
i didn't have a ps5 yet and and
it it felt i was like i get why people
are
are are you know feeling like they have
an unfinished game because
it struggled to hold up under the
capabilities of the ps4 um and
so i even though you know that is a new
game that's not built on the back of
existing tech the way god of war is so
it doesn't
it doesn't apply its apples and oranges
to what you just outlined mike and so it
would be unfair
to hold god of war to that same
sort of scrutiny and that through that
lens i think but i could see how maybe
you know it's like here's the gamer
experience
i put a lot of money into i couldn't get
a ps5 so i'm frustrated and then i put a
lot of money into buying a new release
called cyberpunk that i was super stoked
about and it was [ __ ]
janky as [ __ ] finally after months i buy
uh a ps5 and and then i find out that
the most exciting game that i care about
is not even necessarily i don't even
have to have this thing i just fought
tooth and nail to get
to play it it's like if if that let's
say that's that's my soul gaming
experience for this year because gaming
is just
five percent of my life and that it's
i'm not like living it day in day out
the way we do
that's a series of disappointments
i could see now again nothing ever
justifies then
saying therefore on twitter i'm going to
you know
try to rally up as much hatred and v
like that's never
par for the course but i can see there's
probably
you know some people that experienced
what i just outlined again i'm not
trying to defend it i'm just trying to
explore
explore that one because that one i
initially brushed it off as like ah
people are just entitled blah blah but
then as i thought about it more i
thought
well actually maybe there is some steel
man-able
uh perspective there that that that um
or manchester united
on uh uh could make alana uncomfortable
on a on a call i just can't say anything
about anything
no i know i have no opinion about
anything yes i have absolutely no
opinion on any of this
nothing nothing to contribute to this
you're kind of uh you're yeah you're
just
you're just you know you just need to go
i know right like whatever
and uh and just uh yep call it a day
i i also think just give it a second
like
you know i i can understand the
frustration of getting
something pretty and shiny and new but
this is the same way it's always been
i feel like people forget that it's like
look at the launch titles for ps4
you know they're like there's
manuscripts of like thomas jefferson
complaining about
consoles
we were a launch title y'all and you
know we didn't go
retroactive they didn't go and this is
also going to be about ps3
i think from just like them going like
look we want this game to be successful
we want the developer to
to not be chokehold to the limited base
so i think it's them going
if we just said you were all you're look
you're already a
uh whether you're first party or not
you're already going to be a playstation
exclusive
to then go oh and by the way you're also
your install base is
inherently going to be lower because
we're only going to make you ps5
i can see yeah especially given the
challenges around the ps5 release
specifically i could see them saying
for the sake of inclusivity yeah like
for example i
obviously have no idea if this is even
close to reality but it could be
interesting if that wasn't
the plan originally to have it available
on ps4
and then realizing you know it wouldn't
take that much
to open that you know that sounds like
that would be hard to
do that wouldn't have been a late stage
decision that would have been
i mean if you're making an expansion
essentially to like a ps4 game you're
not going to just turn your back because
that's the other way to look at it right
it's like if you're someone who's not
got a ps5
yet and you love god of war and you want
to play more of it then you know you
want to play on there i get it
it's interesting seeing a first party
that's what's different i just realized
also we're talking about
the what's it called again like um
like um um i'm blanking the the
stockholm syndrome nothing yeah what
it's
yeah like i just realized we're talking
about that which is more like miles
morales
uh yeah yeah i was i i realized i
i was thinking in terms of like the next
full
scoped game oh which is also why
was doing this and that's why i think
horizon zero dawn's gonna be a really
interesting conversation because that is
uh
oh it's realizing zero new one is it but
yeah
yeah i had mixed those in my head
because it felt more
substantive that a full-fledged
huge scale sequel doing this was what
was raising that
but yes of course it actually is a lot
harder to steal man realizing that it's
the
the miles morales equivalent uh uh
understood but it's interesting it's
also something given the budgets of
aaa and especially the massive budgets
of sony first party which obviously they
spend a lot of money
hitting the polish levels they do these
kind of interim titles
do make a lot of financial sense this
idea of like making the essentially the
expansion that is itself like
big enough to justify a boxed release um
you see that from
all of the in-house company in-house
studios at sony it does make sense
and it gives them a nice regular release
cadence because you can be
shipping miles morales but then you can
be right there with ratchet and clank
from the same studio a year or two later
so you can
you don't have to wait six seven years
between how about that insomniac you
know what a great
what a great studio you know what making
great games what a good time did you
answer did you answer troy's question
alana other than chrono trigger
is there like uh i play all video games
austin also it's gonna seem like a joke
to everyone watching because of the
context but i did tell you guys i have
to go right now
but i'm gonna leave the show running um
i don't remember you saying that i think
that that's
actually i think that's an act ryan's
knocking on me
yeah they're right here i'm being
arrested
and there it is there it is uh
all right now she's gone we got the keys
that's sad
what is your answer to this one troy me
oh dude so as dark souls is a good
answer for my like
because i agreed like dark souls the the
design influence the fact that that be
souls like i played all the games that
it's influenced
i've just not played the game if you
launch a genre right yeah you should be
played by every game designer i'm 100
with you yeah that makes sense for sure
um
i i was thinking about this and it's
austin i often talk about this where our
conversations happen
in some form or in the midst of some
form of
uh pedestrian domestic activity like i'm
cooking dinner i'm doing dishes or
whatever
and i was just very often doing dishes
yeah very often i have listened to
troy's dishwashing technique like 4 000
times
so if pam ever says you never do the
dishes i was like i'm just going to hold
up the phone to
austin and be like he does dishes all
the time on the phone with them and then
i hang out
um i i like that austin's a good enough
friend that he would have your back in
this imaginary argument that you're
right actually he would probably have
pam's back he was like you should
probably leave him
it would definitely be one of those like
tyrion lannister moments of trying to
size up where
the power is and go yeah yeah who's
going to win this who's going to be
i'm pretty sure i just want to come out
with the victor party here i don't
really care which side it is
yeah i like we're not really affiliated
or i don't agree with him but
um i had a worse dennis leary joke that
i'm never going to go down okay
um i so i was the name of this and this
is what
drew me to it is like i growing up uh
you know i i've said a lot of times that
i didn't
we didn't have a lot of money and so
there's a lot of of of games that
i was only able to play because i was
over at a friend's house
or i i could get one because it was my
birthday and so my exposure to games was
big
and i've been playing games for a long
time like where before was like pc was
like literally putting in
you know five and a half inch floppy or
whatever like matthew broderick in
in war games um that was even bigger
that wasn't even five and a half that
was like
eight inch whatever it was um the
poppies that were actually floppy
yeah well yeah my five and a half were
floppy and the hard disk was like this
is a new material
but i i i started thinking about this
there's this huge gap
um whether it be like especially like
nintendo 64
um or even like gamecube games or
whatever where
i was at this weird point where i i
wasn't
a teenager anymore but i wasn't making
enough money to be able to do this and
so
i was still missing out and it wasn't
until i released i got my own job and i
was i was making my own money
that i was able to do the things and buy
the things that i wanted to buy
um so ocarina of time
never played it and that's like one
where people go that's like the
godfather of it's not
it's not citizen kane but it's like you
have to see you have to play that game
to be able to understand it's like i
mean i show some solidarity i've not
played it either there you go
really i've got your belly yeah okay
i've not played anything like that
that's what i'm saying
you know the funny the funny thing with
me the ver the closest
to that that i have is that it is
expected amongst composers that you
absolutely
worship the lineage of zelda music
and the majority of it i've always felt
like is fine
that one i always thought
you know koji kondo's real contribution
is the mario theme which i think is
is genuinely a baffling achievement
because you have can you play it for us
austin
what i love is that that the mario theme
is is literally just just the
the like just the chord
you know the fact that it's a it's a
it's a it's a nine chord
[Music]
just the one that alone is to me so
telling
that uh that the lone gesture of that
you can clock it to me that's always
it's like
how many notes did you say it was of a
chord how many fingers are you putting
down
i said it's a ninth chord which isn't
about the number that's about
about how many notes similarly you know
do you can you spot this one off of just
one chord
[Music]
go mike i'm out i'm technically playing
it
uh not quite the right register well
that's why yeah
no sorry if i keep going
[Music]
that's that's it's hitchcock
yeah yeah hitchcock the birds right what
famously the birds has no score in that
film oh there's noises
it's psycho though psycho sorry but what
i love is that it's literally just it
starts with the strings doing that and
you can identify
it's the prologue i was putting it into
games i was like
i was like which mario track is that
yeah yeah that was like that's
a cool [ __ ] yeah um but yeah to me zelda
that theme
is basically like it's sort of a generic
you know you know it's like in that era
of indiana jones and superman and it's
clearly like trying to evoke the same
basic thing
it has peculiarities about it that are
unique to the artistic voice that is
koji kondo but meanwhile mario it's like
so a bunch of japanese developers make a
game about
italian brother so-called plumbers
in some kind of surreal acid trip of a
dinosaur fantasyland
and his and to save a princess and the
and the the music is like swanky lounge
jazz i was like this is the most
incred like the originality of every one
of these lego blocks is actually quite
astounding
so and it's a technical achievement
right so do something that iconic with
the tech at the time in terms of playing
music back it's amazing
yeah they had three they had three
voices you know not only that melody
bass and then a noise generator for
for drums essentially but also just the
the sheer fact that
that was a big left turn for that
franchise right
because you had this ancillary character
for
king kong and then you'd have mario
brothers and then this
really which was kind of like donkey
kong reskinned a little bit
and then you have this whole now now
we're doing this full side scroller
thing
where there's a lot of dynamic assets i
i still have my
my um my emulator that i love to play
and i'll even just kind of like do the
random things like drop me into a game
that i've never
like even heard of or whatever and it's
still
i i go back to the the reason why i like
retro games has nothing to do with
um you know it being hipster and cool
and it's like it's the mustache of
video games but um it is in every way i
look back at the simplicity and
and of design and how at the end of the
day
no matter what your lod is no matter
what your
um micro transactions or anything else
if you can just simply just
honestly dude i would say this if you
weren't here but
you you take something like thomas was
alone and you go
can you if you could just you played it
it's a good game um
it's all right it strikes me at the end
if you can
simplify it down and distill it down to
its quintessence of what it wants to be
that's a good game and there's so many
games that you just go back and go this
is
ghosts and goblins i still go back to
ghosts and goblins it's like that is a
challenging super simple game
that if you could beat that game today
go for it designed to not be beatable
it's designed to be
a sicipian task brilliant
and so many of them uncloned that's the
thing that's always really interesting
is going back to those games
i remember for a long time should i say
which game it was
no i won't there was a game that me and
my business partner were like we have to
do like the modern
remake of this oldness game and yes
sorry
nes game um we have to go back and we
have to do that at some point and then
someone did and it's really frustrated
us because we were like that was going
to be our thing but there's
there's so many of those old games that
like if you put a fresh coat paint on
them would be so neat
was it good the version that was kind of
cloned yeah it was really good
that's the thing like it was really good
it's like okay no they they own that now
that's fine
would you have done it the same way or
do you think that you know completely
differently
completely differently but the it was
one of those things where now that did
such a good job we
i wouldn't want to go and it would feel
obtuse now it would feel hipster to go
and do it the different way because it
would be like oh
yeah but no it's it's it's fascinating
like going back to those old games that
was part of the thinking with solitaire
was like
with soul tech conspiracy was literally
like you could really polish up a
solitaire game nowadays so yeah that's
why we went and did it you know it's
like it's there is definitely there's a
lot of like wisdom and
maybe not the most original way to come
up with a game concept but at the same
time like a lot of these games
you know have been people have been
playing them since we had stones in the
dirt right like
it's it's true story interesting i if if
i continue with you that was really cool
we're so we're doing this future game
show that's that's
put on by games radar um that's
happening this weekend i believe
um and they you know laura and i got to
host it together and we were able to you
know um
uh they were they were just cool working
with us and
they they had everything scripted out
because they needed to for the purpose
of the show but there's there was one
thing specifically they were talking
about um
a certain game didn't matter what it was
but the the point of it was that they
said
or you can wish listed on steam now and
i
was talking about um so you know do this
you know
to find out more you can go here you can
wishlist on steam and i said
and it really when you do that it really
does help that developer
um and they were like what what did you
say and i was like oh i'm sorry i just
like i don't know i lost control of my
mouth for a second there
i threw that in i i was there in my room
like this just like
zlatan uh you were basically the uh
harbinger from mass effect 2 doing the
uh i was i was yeah i was professor
xavier i i got my name wrong three times
but i got there in the end
xavier i was like hey no it's just it's
true it's like uh that i've
i said mike bithell is really the one
that taught me is like it really does
help out they're able to track is like
for for
any developers and all developers it
really helps them see if their game is
on track he said
if you go wish listen so i just wanted
to say hey do this it really does help
people out
and they're like no it's great we just
wanted to make sure that we knew what
you said so we could have it for the
subtitles and i was like oh awesome
um so it's cool stuff like that it's the
same reason why i didn't realize why
people always like
the like and subscribe is just i hate
people saying that on youtube
but i understand why it's because it
helps raise visibility
yeah i think there's so many youtubers
that say it feels like such a cliche to
say that and the moment they do they see
their likes and subscribes go up
yep yeah so we're all we're all working
the algorithm now that's that's
ultimately all any of us are doing in
the content creation business
jamie's trying to take the computer into
thinking we're special jamie colin has a
has a lyric in one of his songs um he
goes sometimes i just want all right
don't have to go outside don't have to
beg you beg you to subscribe and i was
like that's kind of how we all felt it's
like
we're trying to find our feet in this
new landscape
um and it's really really hard sorry
austin what were you going to say
well just off of your kind of pariah for
not playing x thing
i googled just now a list just
no matter what you click on it's going
to be arbitrary but i just kind of
googled like best games of all time just
to find somebody who had aggregated
something and wikipedia has a
actually wikipedia has a pretty good
article because it's basically
aggregating what the
what the top like you know bafta game of
the year versus
ign's game of the year and it just kind
of aggregates like the various
more or less consensus games of the year
going back forever and
you know figuring that some subset of
these will be those that it's just like
you
have to have played it you know yes it
was the game of the year then but
you know oh well time moved on it's not
considered a staple
the way it was in its moment but some
have obviously like golden eye 64
is an example of one that's like it's
only aged better if anything
and um have you played it recently like
it's bad it's terrible it's it's
terrible but it's it was it was
incredible
its time but i mean but it was slow and
i would say fun then play
the campaign is whatever it's playing it
with a friend like well
yeah multiplayer was as a was a godsend
and the whole story about them
secretly like basically ignoring
nintendo to ship it anyway and all that
i loved all that
but i but i um i even liked the campaign
uh but uh but i yeah i played the
living hell out of that game what i
don't mean about it it's aging well or
what i do mean is
you mean it's relevance and it's respect
it is it has only grown
you know it is of course of its time but
but what i was going to say is i'm
actually there's plenty of games on
these lists that i haven't
played uh but there's very few on here
that i think
it reaches the level of how how could
you have never
played shadow the colossus is on there
probably i'm in earlier titles but
um if it if it has [ __ ] like mario i
don't want to
shadow the colossus is yeah no like 2005
you know the the the the games that were
kind of vying for
game of the year are shadow of the
colossus splinter cell chaos theory
resident evil 4 psychonauts
the original guitar hero the original
god of war devil may cry 3 and civ 4.
those are all 2005. um and so like you
see what i mean like some of those
yeah you know he's not one that you're
going to be seeing name checked very
often but was
a decent game it's it's only like the
oscars right like you go back if you
look back at like what
what films actually won oscars like a
lot of time it's like that is not
oh yeah that's not how the record
shakespeare in love
shakespeare in love shakespeare in love
not only won
it it won it won and it won best score
stephen warbuck won best score against
this
the the very last time ever before he
died jerry goldsmith was nominated and
he was beaten by shakespearean love
i have a hard time forgiving that i
don't i don't understand i feel like
somebody had some pictures of people
that they didn't want published
and they were like it's going to be
shakespeare love isn't it either that
and maybe
you get a problem with your brakes when
you're driving home yeah things happen
to good people
i mean it was it was a weinstein movie
to go back to
true here's here's some shenanigans
going on
here's a here's an interesting uh thing
that blew my mind
it shouldn't but it still does reading
through this list of the
those just as i kind of started
scrolling and you know as i hit
games that i'm like yeah no played that
played that played the hell out of that
and or just never played it but no one
no one you know is going to
take me to task over that but what
something that jumped out at me is i was
huge into the
command and conquer franchise and and
the
the two like goliath releases of canada
conquer and red alert the thing that the
thing that
i appreciate now far more than i i
wasn't even aware of is that
red alert came out the next year yeah
that's i only played alert i don't think
i play command maybe i play command
conquer
man you and me austin we need to do red
alert four when the time comes
when he comes talking i will i would
bite their hand off to do well i i
i i was i was happy to dip my toes and
and i scored ea's command and conquer
mobile game that came out
and i we're doing that around the same
time as wick right like i think i think
we talked about it i just didn't it
could be
yeah it was pretty quick in and out it
wasn't a huge scope score
um but it was a i mean it was one of
those like my pitch to them was i'm a
command and conquer fanboy where can i
sign
yeah uh and like i just those game but
yeah red alert in particular
the thing that i loved was when the map
editor
uh when i got a hold on a map editor and
i would make the most
stupid maps to play with my friends like
you know
giant seas of resources and then a wall
that had
like a single tanks width gap in the
middle to just create the most stupid
bottlenecks
and just frustrating stalemates and and
uh
yeah god i love that i'd love them to
bring back i'd love them to do it
in that old school way i don't want them
to modernize it i want that very
traditional
command conquer vibe um did you ever
play handy shots
at that level of rts which were very
simple sorry go on
simple but deep you know did you ever
play i'm sure
andy shot says tooth and tail it's been
on my list forever i've never played it
it's
maybe that's the yeah you're a pariah
now uh that um
that game was definitely a love letter
to the command and conquer era visually
like it's a 90s style pixel art
dressed up and beautiful you know and
but the thing that was so
fun about it was his design premise was
can i make a couch multiplayer rts um
and like an rts that is natively mapped
to a controller
and isn't awkwardly stumbling the way
starcraft and command and conquer really
just should never be off of a
pc um and but
also works well as a like a split screen
um and you know hell
if he didn't do it i think that games
multiplayer is so goddamn fun
and yeah i just i missed that era of rts
we're going to rock up we're going to
pitch troy
as the general that you're working for
opposite michael ironside
megalite's side mega you know what to do
save money on ironside just have that
foreign can we get troy in a bald cap
i got a landslide's great i got to work
with him once on uh i think there's a
red faction that we got to work with
yeah
he's like just sorry um i got a beauty
bounce
i gotta i gotta get the hell out of here
you see this it's like
slowly devolving it actually doesn't
look like it at all
yeah the mess is all over here moving to
an undisclosed
location oh you're moving as well i'm
about to move are you
tis the season yeah we're all getting
sick of our houses i guess yeah moving
out to the country
gonna eat a lot of peaches what's your
move
you're the same area are you moving
further away
oh i'm staying in like the same area i'm
just uh i'm just
i'm just getting a house finally
becoming a homeowner at 35. it's gonna
be exciting hey man
um i'll come see yours you come see mine
you can always come straight it's good
um i'm glad we got to talk
i've missed you guys yeah thanks for
joining thanks for being a guest on our
podcast
yeah thank you so very much austin come
on now
alana i have a perfect attendance record
and i'm
i'm i'm holding you have haven't you you
you you're the only person who appears
that's the truth if
ever this show were to achieve the
audience size to be a pub quiz question
you'd be the answer to the question
and in fairness member of the cast of
play watch listen has been in every
episode
but i i i would be remiss not to say
that it is due to the graciousness
of my colleagues here that that is the
case because i was the one who
couldn't do it this week on the day we
had planned and
warned everyone at the last second and i
publicly flagellate
to make penance you can't do that on
television
um but i am going to say hi everybody
welcome to playwright's uh that was
elana pierce
i have no idea if i'm doing this right
i'm just troy baker
you are that's austin wintry and that's
mike bithell
i wouldn't whatever we do alana does
this i don't we don't do this um
she's probably here the whole time just
seeing how we behave
what you're saying about somebody taking
your head just to write reports of the
lawyer
alana writes austin composes
my designs and i act i don't know
that's stupid all right whatever um
that's our out
that's all right we'll see you next week
bye